あ どうぞ  アッパマーラーという言葉があったんですが
アッパマーラーの行為と善行為は同じなのか
同じです  他に質問などございませんか？ まあアッパマーラわからない方々に対してアッパマーラの不放逸ですね
怠らなくというね 単語を怠らなくっていうことは
この瞬間瞬間の行為に対してちょこっと知恵を働かす
気づきを入れるというね
ことです 関係ない質問でも聞く分は損しませんので
はい  お坊様方に悪魔が出てくるということを今日読んでるんですけれども
まあそれはやっぱり本当にマーラが出てきて
お坊さんに誘惑したりとか
お坊さん心の中の一つの葛藤をマーラというものに表しているのか
どうなのかなと  それはそのお坊様は何者かということによりますけど
お坊様は本当にもうあの聖者であるならばね
マーラっていうのはそのもう外から来るね
邪魔者なんですね 修行中の場合はそれはちょっと別なんですけどね
マーラは 5種類いてね
で ブッダはそれはただの宗教用語にしているんです
悪魔という言葉はなくて
で 一番わかりやすいマーラっていうのは
我々の妄想システムなんです
だから妄想するんだから怒る
妄想するんだから嫉妬する
妄想するんだから落ち込む
妄想するんだから腹が立つ
もうだからすべて人間の問題は妄想そのものなんです
妄想というのは 我々すごい胸を張ってやっていることなんですね
いくらやめなさいと言ってもやめたくはない
だから自己破壊は自分でやってるんです
一番マーラ第1はそれなんです
だから瞑想したってもうまくいかないのは自分の妄想の結果なんです
妄想に負ける それがマーラに負けたということで
それははっきり私は瞑想を指導するというか
教えているはずなんです
修行する人は誰と戦うのかで自分の妄想と戦いなさいと
それがマーラですよ 悪魔だよと
悪魔は自分の心にいるんだよと
堂々と 別に無許可で入り込んでいるわけじゃないんです
硬く侵入しているわけじゃないんです
我々はもうもろてあげて
どうぞと歓迎して入れているんです
それで養っているんです
マーラを で そこでもう戦って追い出しなさいと
追い出したところでマーラに勝ったことになって
それが悟りということなの
だから妄想はもう停止させた時点でもう悟りは開ける
そこは誰でもものすごい気をつけなくちゃいけない
じりじりと経験できるマーラなんです
他はね まあまあまあ スカンダ・マーラという単語がありまして
五蘊はマーラであると
五蘊っていうのは色受想行識という体でしょ
体と心でしょうね それがマーラというのは
煩悩はそこから生まれるんだからと
また無常で壊れていくし
これは嫌でしょうし それで人間が悩み苦しむ羽目になるんだから
五蘊に対する執着をマーラと言ってますけどね
でも別に修行ではそんなにそこは無常であるということが分かれば解決はする
サンカーラ・マーラという言葉で
行 サンカーラっていうのは心の中から生まれてくる衝動的なエネルギーなんですね
だからそれもマーラであると
貪瞋痴あるんだから 衝動はいつでも貪瞋痴なんです
だから人間やっていることは全部自分の不幸だけ作ってくれるものになるんです
だから感情で何とか衝動でやっていることっていうのは
それ自体もマーラ の行為であると
次は何ですか？それから人が死ぬことをマーラと言うんですね
その場合はマーラっていうのは死という単語で
死をとか何とかとか文学的に使って
それは死そのものなんですね 5
番目になってくるのはデーヴァプッタ・マーラという
このある神のことなんですね
天界にいる それはもう天界六天にいる一番高いところにいる神で
あのグループはもうたまたまこのブッダのね
弟子たちといっても 阿羅漢たちに聖者たちに
あるいはものすごい真剣に人に涅槃の道を教える場合とかね
その時は来てちょこっと迷惑をかけたり
雰囲気を壊したり 人々の集中力を散乱させたりしちゃうんですよ
聞かしてやらんぞとかね
まあまあまあそれぐらいのことです
だから経典に出てくる場合は
このあの三界のマーラ神ですから
その場合はほとんど阿羅漢たちの対立だから
神のことですよ 煩悩の場合はそこら辺明確に書いていると思います
そのマーラ神はこの仏教徒教で言ってる悪魔みたいな
もう敵とか何とかっていうことでもない
ただの邪魔者で 邪魔するだけのことでも
あまり敵視はしていないんです
なんで最近マーラの話ばっかり聞くんですかね
もうもう 優子さんも聞いたし
昨日も聞かれたし 昨日じゃなくて木曜日も聞かれたし
インターネットでももう書いてあったし
ああ でもこれはあまり明確に言いたくはない
みんなに まあまあ言いたくないところもいろいろありますけどね
はい  今日のお話に関してなんですけれども
普段の行為の中で迷ってしまうということが結構あるんですけれど
例えば知恵を働かそうと思っても
なんかどっちにしたらいいのかな？と考えるとか迷っちゃうということがあるんですけれども
迷いっていうのは もうそれ自体不善行為になってしまうんでしょうか
妄想の結果で  妄想の結果が出て迷うんだったら
それは不善行為でしょう
なぜならば 迷い時間がもったいないでしょ
そうすると行為をする時間がちょっと遅れるでしょうね
それもそれ自体で その場合は不善行為になりますね
妄想の結果で迷っちゃうと
もうただ単にこの場合はどちらがいいのかというわからない場合は
それは妄想じゃなくて
もうただ結果どうなるのかわからないと
どうすればいいかわからない
それならごく普通なこと
だからそれは別にもう不善ということじゃないんです
まあいろいろこの場合どうしようかな
どんなどんな方がいいな
いいでしょうかということか
よく一般的に出てくる迷いっていうのは
それはもうただの行為で
その時でも巧みな人はもうできるだけ短い時間でなんとか解決をする
ずっとディレンマにぶつけて
もう迷ってずっと迷ってるの
それ悪い なぜかというと
全部その時間無駄になるんだからね
迷ってる時間というのはもう停止時間みたいなもんでしょ
動かない時間だからね
それならそれはできるだけ短くする
迷うということからは
この綺麗に解放されるということは
まあほぼありえないんですよ
この世の中では で それはどうしようもない
時間というのは短い 人にも
その時間で何するのかというと
したいものっていうのはいくつか出てくるんですよ
でもできるのは一個だけなんで
その時間の中で だから迷いは全くない生き方っていうのは
その時点ではあのプラクティカル的な面ではありえないんです
3日休みですから 外国旅行でもしようかなと
まず決めると でも外国旅行って言った途端
ものすごい幅が広いでしょうに
でも頭に浮かぶどんな国にも行けないでしょうに
3日間しかないんだからね
だから実行できるのは 1個だけで
そこでシンガポール行こうか
あるいはマレーシアに行こうかとかね
あるいはもうロサンゼルス
ロスに行こうかとかね
そこでちょこちょこっと考えて
それで 1つ決めなくちゃいけない
それは早くも決めた方がいいんです
3日間もそれで迷ってたらいけないでしょうね
パリもいいし ロスもいいし
シンガポールも悪くないし
やっぱりマレーシアも最近インドネシアバリはどうでしょうかとか
その辺で 3日もかかっちゃうと
もういけないんですからね
だからこの日常生活の中
そういう具体的にいろいろ迷いには立ち向かいますよ
それは避けられない 理由は時間と現実の問題なんですね
時間は 1本しかない やることはその 1本の上でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
1個しかできない それでどちらにするのかというところでは迷っちゃうんです
そこはできるだけ早く決めるというね
ことです 妄想のせいでそっちを迷うことは
これはもう明らかなすごい不善
不善行為なんです はい
そんなところです  善行為というのは
その時瞬間瞬間にこれは善か不善かっていうことを考えることなんですか
巧みかないかと 上手にやったかないかということです
やっぱりそれがいい巧みかそうじゃないかっていうことを常に考えておくこと
そうそう  例えば結果が本人は巧みと思ってやった結果が
周りの人にとって巧みではなかった場合は
その時自分が巧みだと思った瞬間は善行になるんですか
まあ自分にとってはね
自分にとっては 世の中やっぱりみんな
でもその問題起きませんと思いますけどね
いいとか悪いとかっていうのは
その人それぞれ思いがあって
巧みっていうことは いい悪いと関係ないんですよ
いい悪いと単語 だから私はあえてその単語は使ってなかったでしょ
巧みっていうと  みんなすぐ褒めますよ
例えばカップを洗うとね
サッと水道にサッとこうやって置いちゃうとね
いい加減とそう思っちゃうでしょうに
カップ洗うぐらいの問題だったらいいんですけど
だから本当はもっと小さいんですよ
問題は だからこの大きく見るところに巧みじゃないんですよ
実際やってるのは 1 秒単位の行為なんですよ
これシンプルにしなくちゃいけないんですよ
これ 1年がかりで考えてるんだから
そこは巧みじゃないんで
思考は  たまたま昨日映画を見て
そのもう一生治らない人が私を殺してくれと言うんですね
病院で その頼まれた人はすごく悩むわけですよ
なんで悩むの？ だって殺したらやっぱいけそうなことできないし
その人を愛してるし そんなことつらいしできない
簡単で私にそんな権利ないんだよと
それだけで別に悩む必要ないでしょう
あなたに言う権利もないし
私に殺す権利はないんだよと
死ぬまで生きる自由があるんじゃないかと
苦しいと言ったって知ったもんじゃないんだよと
いうのは巧みな答えなんですけど
なんだっていうことは
その人の話に乗ったっていうことなんです
それは隅に自分が賛成しちゃったんです
これ巧みな思考じゃないんです
乗った時点で だから巧みでないことをやっちゃったんだから
後で悩む羽目になったんです
だからそうやってこのちっちゃなところで判断してください
あまり大胆に取っちゃうと
もう人間にそんな能力ないんですよ
今やってることは 10
年経ったらどんな結果になるかとか
そんな能力ないでしょうに
そういう風に考える必要ないんです
子育てしたって もうどんな人間になるか分かったもんじゃないでしょうに
だからその日で その日で
その 1時間で その 30分で巧みに子育てをする
それで十分です  ちょっとよろしいですか
はい  ちょっと全然違うんですけどね
日本の教義の中で般若心経とかありますよね
これは全体としてどのような内容に
いや その般若心経はご教典ですね
どのような内容を表していたんですか？ それは私分かりませんね
私はもうその世界のボスじゃないんだからね
後ろに座ってますけどね
聞いてみたら その禅の世界でどういうふうに見ているのかということは
私は説明しても それはもう明らかに批判だから
般若心経に対しては不親切ですよ
私はむちゃくちゃ批判するんだからね
だから私 ちょっと答えにくいんですよ
その禅やら大乗仏教ではね
大事な経典だから どんなものを通して見ているのかどうかね
そちらの方の方々から聞いた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
私たちは え？何？ テレビではね
日本のお坊さんがよく解説をします
日本の仏教の中ではいいお経とされています
それは私には関係ないです
正反対 正反対なんです
我々から見れば ブッダの教えから見ればね
要するに合理性を持ってないってことですね
だって悪魔払いにも般若心経
祝福にも般若心経 葬式にも般若心経
もう何でもあれでやろうとしているんですけどね
般若心経は何も持ってないんじゃないかな
何も意見持ってないでしょ
結局はね だからぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃ言うだけで
なんとかいいことあるんじゃないかって
そういうちょっとした迷信的な信仰だと思いますけどね
その経典自体が論理性がないし
で 付け加えて付け加えて作ってるんですよ
まだ神秘系でしょうしね
なんか御利益あるというか
なんかちょっとした超能力みたいな何か力あると思ってるしね
まあそういうのはやっぱり初期仏教的じゃないんです
原典のものからはだいぶ改竄されてる
ものすごい改竄です すごい
だって最後に呪文で終わっちゃいますからね
だから大乗仏教の歴史は全部入ってるようなもんですよ
あんな短い文章の中に
だから大乗仏教のスタートは空論から始めたんでしょ
それで色即是空と始まるんですよ
それから空即是色といったところで
自分で自己破壊 自己矛盾するんですね
それで空論も分かってないというところがよく見える
要する色即是空ですけど
空即是色じゃありませんし
それで大乗仏教の発展で初めであった空論がわからなかったんだから
どんどん大乗仏教は崩れていって
あらゆる宗派が出てきて
最後にじゃあ呪文唱えちゃあいいやと
これでもう偉大なるあれやってことで終わっちゃったんだから
その順番にずっと並んでるんですよ
それから大乗仏教の目的はこの小乗仏教とブッダの教えをね
もう貶して それを潰す
敵は 大乗仏教の敵はブッダだからね
キリスト教の悪口言わないんですよ
仏教の悪口を言うんです
だから仏教を非難することで
もう死生体もないわ もう因果法そんなのは全部空やとかね
輪廻も解脱もそんな全部もう同じやとかね
まあそうやってもいい加減になっちゃって
それから盛大なんとかということで
これこそ呪文でやるとギャーギャーで終わっちゃいます
あれは大乗の歴史そのものなんです
だから その点で見ればね
ちっちゃな短い文章で
テキストの半ページ半分もならないでしょうね
よくまとめたもんだなと思います
だから これ私のテーラワーダの見解であってね
だからそれは大乗仏教で般若心経を大事に信仰する人々にとってはすごい失礼な言い方になります
だから意味理解したければ
その専門家の方々にどういうものかと聞いて
もう反論出してみてとかね
そんなした方がいいと思います
で テーラワーダからはあれを分析することさえもできない
初めからおかしいんだから
もうそのままゴミになっちゃうんですね
難しいですね  うん まあだから矛盾ばっかり並び替えちゃうと
これ難しいんですよ 解読するのは
だからこの法華経と般若心経っていうのは結構怪しくて
もう何も中身がないんですよ
もうすごい意味がある大乗経典がありますよ
あるテーマがあって このテーマをずっと分析して持っていく経典はありますけど
それならこちらも比較してもう評価するなりに何でもできますけどね
この 2つの経典はもういい加減ゴミ箱に捨ててくださいという気持ちになるんですね
法華経にしたっても これからすごい教えを教えてやるぞと始まるでしょうに
これは太鼓叩くわ もう雷は落ちるわ
いろんなこと起きるんだけど
それで経典も終わってるんです
お前ずっと自慢して何言いたかったんでしょうか
ないでしょうに お化けは出るわ
神々は出るわ あれやこれやとかね
えらい部隊の準備して何もなくはい終了ですと
幕が落ちるんです 上がってもないのに
そんなのはもう中学生ぐらいの作品でもないんですよ
中学生に論文書いたって
もういくらぐちゃぐちゃであろうとも
なんとかまとめちゃいますからね
何章にも渡ってるでしょうに
突然観音なんて一番日本で人気ある
観音経 観音論でしたっけ
この法華経の何番目の章か覚えてないんですけどね
観音の力がなんとか力
なんとかできてなんとか力とかね
もうぐちゃぐちゃですね
あれと法華経は何の関係あるのかと聞きたいんですけど
だからこの古いものに価値あるという固定概念が問題ですよ
価値がいつでも中身にあるんであって
これは古いか新しかっていうことでもないんです
例えば私のこんな言い方っていうのは
日本の方々にとってはものすごい
あの耳障りやと思いますよ
平気で今までね 長い間尊敬したものはね
もう平気でゴミ扱いするんだからね
それは本当はやってはいけないことなんですけど
私は言いたいのはそういうことじゃなくて
ただ古いんだからといって価値があるわけじゃないんです
大乗経典の中で般若心経は結構古いんですけど
価値がないんですよ もっと古い他の大乗経典がありまして
そちらにはそれなりにすごい思想体系はできている
これは思想体系さえもできてないんですね
また法華経もそうでしょうし
例えば浄土のなんとかなんとか経典がありますね
阿弥陀様はなんとか何とか
その場合はテーマをはっきりしているんですよ
阿弥陀さんという人がいて
40何種類の誓願を立てて
まあこれで頑張って今はもう待っているんだぞとかね
そこでテーマを一つ決めてしっかりと作品を作るならば
まあそれはそれで もう勉強もできるし
批判もできるし 比較もできるんですよ
うん だから作品としても成り立ててないものはもう没収するしかないんですけど
人間というのはそういうもの好きになっちゃいますよ
何かテーマに書いているものはあまり好きじゃないんですね
それで日本の方々ももうみんな自分の般若心経の解説を持ってるんですよ
だから人に聞けば説明は種類になるんです
1万人に聞けば1万種類の説明
説法ですよ ということは
アタックする人がもう頭がこんがらがっちゃって
こうやってもう壊れて終わるんです
そのそのお坊様は そのその宗派の人
そのその地域の人は自分の般若心経っていうのを持ってるんだから
だから随分自分勝手に解説するんです
私から見ればね で 般若心経はこれという定めた解説はないんです
例えば曹洞宗のお坊さんに般若心経の説法を聞く
真宗のお坊さんに般若説法を聞くと違うんですよ
説法内容 で 現代人ももう宗教と関係ない現代人も般若心経を勉強するそうと思って
また好き勝手なことをやったりする
まあ一回だけ私もまあ誰かにね
ちょこっとした論文にちょっと協力してあげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃって
あの まあ本人はもう発表するだけで能力はなくて
じゃあいいや もう全部もうまとめて整理してあげるそうとね
まあで もうもう 1日2日で全部揃って慌てて本人に送ったんですけど
論文書いてね これやと
でも気をつけてくださいと
もうほとんどの学者が知らない
発見してないポイントももう結構書いてますからと
そこら辺は自分で理解しなきゃものすごく危ないんだと
注意点も入れて まあ論文を書いて送っちゃった
だから私の研究はその程度で
自分はやりたくはない
触りたくもない あれコンパクトですからね
小さくて そこで人気あるでしょうね
まあとにかくそれ以上は喋れません
この度も同じバイオマス研究室なんですけども
うつ気分障害を治すにはどうしたらいいでしょうか
だからこの気を説法したね
善行為にそむんだそうと決めるだけでも
なりますよ 嘘の人の問題はそういうことを全然やらないことだけですよ
方法は教えても教えてもやらないでしょ
だからまあ お手上げですけどね
だから今日説明したこのあんな大胆なことではなくてね
ただちょこっとカップ洗いくらい
掃除洗濯するぐらい 階段上がったり上ったたり
駅まで歩くぐらい そういう切符買うぐらい
そういうちっちゃなちっちゃなことはすごく丁寧にする
なんかもう大体まあこれ肉体的に病気になってるんだから
まあ二 三週間ぐらいはかかると思いますけど
二 三週間の努力はしないんですね
私は嘘だからもうやめたと
そんなことを自分の成績でね
病気になって それぐらい努力もしたくないとね
言うならばね 普通の人なら 1日でびっくりしますよ
この善行為するぞと決めちゃえば 1日でびっくりしますよ
人生変わりますから 知恵が現れてきますから
薄菜のように このものすごく病気になっている場合はね
まあそれも長い間自分が思考が間違っていた結果だから
これ治すためには まあちょっと二
三週間  1ヶ月間ぐらいはかかる
そこはちょっと我慢してほしいんですね
例えば麻薬依存した人が麻薬足そうとすると
これ半年以上苦労しなきゃできんでしょうに
1日で何とかしてくれと言ったって
その半年ぐらいあの治療を受けて
ものすごい肉体的な苦痛もこらえて挑戦しなきゃいけないんですよ
それは麻薬を断つためにアドバイスする人が悪いんじゃなくて
その人のせいで自分のせいでしょうに
麻薬依存したんだから
だから悪いことをした結果で
それはちょっと苦しみはあります
だから嘘の方々にしても
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でも何でも
やっぱりやりづらいなとか
やる気はなくなるなということは当然あります
そこは文句言う権利はない
挑戦しなくちゃいけないのです
普通の人にもヴィパッサナーとか難しいんだから
これ 10倍難しいんですよ
でも他の方法はないんだからね
薬使ってももう死体になるしか方法ないんですよ
だから神経何とかの薬なんか使っちゃえばもう生きながら死体でいられますけど
それで嘘治ったわけじゃないでしょうに
だから今日の話でも答えはあります
だから問題は何か実行しようと思ったら
もう 1時間で嫌になっちゃうという
この病気に悩んでる人の問題なんですね
そこは一人で踏ん張らなくちゃいけないんです
私の場合は これは大変難しいんだと
でもやるぞという決まりが必要なんです
大体二 三週間で脳細胞が新しく変わってはいきます
はい それ十分でしょうね
細胞が  はい じゃあこちら
細胞が入れ替わるというのは細胞が入れ替わるということですか？ネットワークが入れ替わる
いろいろ だから脳っていうのは開発はちょこっと遅いんだからね
でも新しい脳細胞が生まれるんですよ
昔は生まれないと思っていたんですけど
でも今はもう脳細胞も生まれる再生するんだという医学者は言ってます
どちらかというと私 知ったもんじゃないんですけどね
で 私は中間を取って ネットワークはもうネットワークが構成するのはもうはっきりしています
脳のね だから新しいネットワークができちゃうんです
それにも時間はかかりますよ
1日で すぐ神経がね シナプス作るわけじゃないんだからね
はい  普通我々というか
私が考えると 生き方としては八正道を行くとか
そういうふうにすぐ考えちゃうんですけども
ここの受けではですね
そんな偏りというと変ですけども
そんなこと言わないで
とりあえず丁寧に生きてみろっていうのは
そういうふうに捉えてもいいんですか？それともこれは八正道
丁寧ではなくて腐るんですから
巧みに生きてみなさいと
だから八正道って巧みな生き方でしょうに
同じことですよ 消失っていうのは巧みな思考でしょ
正見というのは巧みな見解でしょ
同じこと言ってる はい
ではどうもありがとうございます